BUT FIRST, 24 HOURS TO VICTORY.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE"."
THEY NEVER CONSIDERED HIM A
LEGITIMATE PRECEDENT.
THEY COULDN’T ALLOW THEMSELVES
TO.
AFTER ALL, IF A MAN WITH ZERO
POLITICAL EXPERIENCE COULD TAKE
DOWN THE CLINTONS, THE OBAMA’S,
THE BUSHES, THE ENTIRE MEDIA
ESTABLISHMENT, IN A LEGITIMATE
ELECTION, WELL, WHAT WOULD THAT
HAVE SET UP AT THE DEMOCRATIC
BRAND?
EARLY ON, LEFT-WING ACTIVISTS,
THE DEEP STATE, AND THE D.C.
SWAMP DECIDED TO DEVOTE ALL OF
THEIR WAKING HOURS TO A SMEAR
AND SLASH CAMPAIGN WITH THE GOAL
OF CONVINCING YOU THAT THIS
TRUMP PRESIDENCY WAS INVALID.
>> I DON’T SEE THIS
PRESIDENT-ELECT IS A LEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT.
>> THERE IS A CLOUD OF
ILLEGITIMACY HANGING OVER THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> AND ILLEGITIMATE AND CRIMINAL
REGIME IN THE AMERICAN
WHITE HOUSE.
>> HE IS AN ILLEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT, IN MY MIND.
>> LOOK, I ABSOLUTELY AGREE.
>> HE KNOWS HE IS AN
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: AND THREE YEARS
LATER, UNDETERRED BY THE MUELLER
FLAMEOUT, THE DEMOCRATS ARE AT
IT AGAIN.
THIS TIME, THEIR OUTLANDISH
CLAIM EMERGES FROM THE
IMPEACHMENT CIRCUS ITSELF.
WE ALL KNOW, UNLESS SOMETHING
REALLY BIZARRE HAPPENS, THE NEXT
24 HOURS, PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
SURELY BE ACQUITTED BY THE
SENATE.
AND THAT SHOULD BE THE LAST WORD
ON IT, RIGHT?
WRONG.
>> HE WILL NOT BE ACQUITTED.
YOU CANNOT BE ACQUITTED IF YOU
DON’T HAVE A TRIAL.
>> NO TRIAL, NO VINDICATION.
NO VINDICATION FOR THE
PRESIDENT, OR ANYONE ELSE.
>> IT CANNOT BE A TRUE ACQUITTAL
IF IT’S NOT A FAIR TRIAL.
>> A TRIAL WITHOUT TRUTH,
WITHOUT KEY EVIDENCE, WITNESSES,
DOCUMENTS, WOULD RENDER THE
PRESIDENT’S ACQUITTAL MEETING
LES.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
THAT THEY KEEP STRICT.
SO THE DEMOCRAT POSITION, JUSTLY
UNDERSTAND, IS ANY ACQUITTAL IN
A TRIAL WHERE THEY DIDN’T GET
THEIR WAY IS ILLEGITIMATE.
IT’S A CLASSIC HEADS I WIN AND
TAILS YOU LOSE SCENARIO, SO
PREDICTABLE.
DON’T BUY FOR A SECOND THE
ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT
WITNESSES OR DOCUMENTS.
IT’S NOT!
THIS IS ABOUT POWER.
IF TWO OR THREE OR TEN WITNESSES
WERE FOLLOWED BY AN ACQUITTAL OF
TRUMP, YOU WOULD STILL HEAR
NANCY AND KAMALA CHALLENGING THE
OUTCOME.
THIS IS HOW THE DEMOCRATS ALWAYS
PLAY THE GAME.
REMEMBER, TO THIS DAY, THEY
DON’T CONSIDER BRETT KAVANAUGH A
LEGITIMATE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
JUSTICE.
>> THE VERY FACT THAT HE IS
THERE, THAT HE WAS CONFIRMED,
MAKES HIM AN ILLEGITIMATE
JUSTICE.
>> HE’S GOING TO BE ON THE
SUPREME COURT, WITH A HUGE TAINT
AND A BIG ASTERISK AFTER HIS
NAME.
>> THERE WILL BE A CLOUD AND A
TAINT HOVERING OVER HIM AND ANY
OPINION HE ISSUES.
>> Laura: THEY ARE EVEN THE
SAME PEOPLE, SAME STUFF.
THEY DON’T CONSIDER ANY
SUCCESSES OF THIS PRESIDENCY TO
BE LEGITIMATE VICTORIES FOR HIM.
EVEN ON ISSUES OF A AGREE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON, THAT’S THE
AMAZING THING HERE.
WHILE BEING HUNTED AND TRACKED
LIKE WILD GAME ON THE SERENGETI,
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE DELIVERED
SUSTAINED PEACE AND
UNPRECEDENTED PROSPERITY TO THIS
COUNTRY.
COURSE, MAJOR TRADE DEALS,
MASSIVE ECONOMIC SUCCESS,
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM, VA
REFORM, DECLINING OPIOID DEATHS.
BUT THE PELOSI, SCHIFF, SCHUMER,
NADLER -- THESE ARE JUST FLUKES.
TO PUT IT A DIFFERENT WAY, THE
ROOTS OF A POISONOUS,
ILLEGITIMATE, PRESIDENTIAL TREE.
HOW IRONIC THAT THIS ODIOUS
IMPEACHMENT ODYSSEY IS, ITSELF,
THE EPITOME OF AN ILLEGITIMATE
UNDERTAKING.
>> THIS ENTIRE PROCEEDING HERE
IS NOT A FRUIT OF THE POISONOUS
TREE.
IT IS THE FRUIT OF A PROCEEDING
THAT WAS FATALLY DEFICIENT IN
DUE PROCESS FROM THE START TO
THE BEGINNING, AND AS A RESULT
OF THAT, IT PRODUCED A RECORD
THAT IS TOTALLY UNRELIABLE,
CAN’T BE RELIED ON HERE FOR ANY
CONCLUSION OTHER THAN ACQUITTING
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: IF ANYTHING IS
ILLEGITIMATE, IT IS WHAT
ADAM SCHIFF, NADLER, THE WHOLE
CREW DID IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, COURTESY OF A
WHISTLE-BLOWER NO ONE CAN
QUESTION AND IN IG WHOSE
TRANSCRIPT NO ONE CAN READ.
AND ONE MORE POINT OF IRONY HERE
HERE.
AFTER IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT
BASED ON THE UKRAINE ACTIONS
THAT THEY CLAIM WERE POLITICALLY
AND PERSONALLY MOTIVATED, TWO OF
THE TOP HOUSE MANAGERS MAY BE
DRIVING THIS AGONIZING EPISODE
IN LARGE PART TO BOLSTER THEIR
OWN POLITICAL FUTURE, THAT’S
RIGHT, SCHIFF AND
HAKEEM JEFFRIES ARE NOW DUBBED
THE TWO SUPERSTARS OF THE
IMPEACHMENT DRAMA.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
"DANCING WITH THE STARS" IS
ABOUT AS HIGH AS THESE TWO WILL
EVER ARISE.
WELL, ANYONE AND EVERYONE KNOWS
HOW THIS MOVIE ENDS.
THE PRESIDENT WILL NOT BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE, AND THE
DEMOCRATS WILL CONTINUE WASTING
PRECIOUS TIME AND OUR MONEY
ATTEMPTING TO ENTRAP HIM, OR
JUST SMEAR HIM UNTIL THE
ELECTION.
IN CALLING TRUMP AND HIS
FORTHCOMING ACQUITTAL
ILLEGITIMATE, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
KETTLES CALLING THE POT BLACK.
WITH EACH CRAZY UTTERANCE, THEY
DEMEAN THEIR DIMINISHED
CREDIBILITY AND EXPOSE THEIR OWN
ABUSE OF POWER.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN END THE DEMOCRATS
REIGN OF TERROR AND THE HATEFUL
CYCLE THEY HAVE TRAPPED US ALL
IN.
DELIVERANCE IS JUST AROUND THE